[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 percent discount on
a wide range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
assalamu alaikum
so how are you guys doing many of you
are anticipating the podcast on the 13th
of december with me and jordan peterson
this is still insha'allah happening so
there's nothing nothing new there
but what is new
is that i am going to be doing on the
same day a recording of
a format called the opposing views
uh podcast or format which is on
jordan peterson's daughter michaela
peterson's youtube channel and on
youtube
and the opponent that i'm going to have
is iron hersey ali and this is going to
be filmed on the 13th of december and
probably released shortly thereafter so
please make sure that you watch out for
that wassalamualaikum warahmatullahi
foreign